[Music]
on this Saturday Night midf Flight
bright the panel of a Boeing plane blows
out midair one of the guys that was
there his shirt was sucked out and his
phone was sucked out the firsthand
accounts the emergency landing and the
future of the fleet winter is coming in
Nova Scotia there's this thing with the
weather it's unpredictable Racing for a
winter wallup out
east and lining out for the long awaited
powder out
west after facing near
Extinction how Africa's mountain
gorillas have staged a
comeback global national with Baron aser
good evening to you thanks for joining
us tonight that what would happen if
scenario some of us play out in our
minds while sitting in the window seat
happened last night on an Alaskan
Airlines flight an entire cabin pan
panel was sucked out midair the plane a
brand new Boeing 737 max9 jetliner today
US Federal officials have ordered the
immediate grounding of some of those
aircraft here's a closer look at the
hole left in the airplane somehow no one
was seriously hurt 177 passengers and
crew used oxygen masks as the
depressurized plane made an emergency
landing Abigail Bean has the firsthand
accounts in how the frightening ordeal
is renewing safety concerns about bowing
planes we just deiz that we declared an
emergency with a sudden door shaped hole
passengers describe as almost as big as
a refrigerator the Alaska Airlines crew
member tells air traffic control the
plane needs to return to Portland we
have 177 passengers on board the plane
was able to land safely with some wild
stories from the air one of the guys
that was there his shirt was sucked out
and his phone was sucked out I heard
heard like a big bang and I didn't know
exactly what was going
on but um I look up and the oxygen masks
were hanging from the ceiling and then I
look to my left and there's this huge
chunk part of the airplane just like
missing I heard the a pop noise I felt
the wind come forward and then it came
back it hit me in the face I was trying
to make sense of what's going on it was
a trip from Hell the plane had just
recent ly taken off passengers credit
everyone still wearing their seat belts
for the lack of serious injuries the
piece of fuselage sucked away was a
panel covering an optional rear midplane
emergency exit Saturday the US Federal
Aviation Administration issued a
temporary grounding of
171 Boeing Max NES worldwide for
immediate inspections Boeing said it
supports the decision and deeply regrets
the impact of the event it puts a
question mark on the on Boeing's
uh production inspection for sure this
is just the latest in a run of problems
for Boeing's Max Fleet the max was
grounded worldwide for nearly two years
after two crashes blamed on cockpit
software killed 346 people in Ethiopia
and Indonesia and just last week Boeing
asked Airlines to inspect the Jets for a
potential loose bolt in the rudder
control system and I think for me you
know it's it's time for a new design and
stop tweaking Aviation expert John grock
points to Boeing's model of tweaking
older models to bring new planes to
Market quickly as a potential issue but
still he reassures Canadians they're
safe to fly this is a safe airplane the
max airplanes are are well-designed
they're operat of thousands of them in
the air no Canadian Airlines have Max
NES in their Fleet the transport
Minister's office tells Global News
they're watching and waiting for the
result of Investigations by the FAA and
Bo
Abigail bman Global News Ottawa in Japan
safety experts are searching for the
flight voice recorder after a deadly
Runway Collision this week heavy
machinery is removing debris from the
severely burned Japan Airlines plane at
Tokyo's Hena airport investigators are
looking for crucial information on what
caused the collision with a small Coast
Guard Plane on Tuesday killing five crew
members all 379 people on the passenger
plane safely escaped within 18 minutes
of Landing as the aircraft was engulfed
in flames and that Coast Guard Plane it
was set to deliver Aid to those affected
by Japan's 7.6 magnitude earthquake that
struck the country on New Year's Day
more than 120 people are now dead and
more than 200 are still missing days
after the Quake leveled homes and
wrecked infrastructure on the country's
West Coast despite wet weather hampering
efforts the search for survivors
continues in one area Crews rescued a
90-year-old woman trapped in a collapsed
house for days around 30,000 people
remain displaced many staying in
government shelters some have opted to
sleep in their vehicles over fears of
aftershocks to the escalating tensions
in the Middle East right now Lebanese
militant group Hezbollah has fired a
barrage of rockets into Israel today
Israel retaliated swiftly launching a
series of strikes into Southern Lebanon
Hezbollah fired up to 60 Rockets into
Northern Israel calling the attacks a
preliminary response after the
assassination of hamas's senior leader
in Beirut on Tuesday the iran-backed
militant group's leader says his
Fighters destroyed a large number of
Israeli vehicles and tanks US Secretary
of State Anthony blinkin is in the
region trying to calm those tensions as
fears grow of a wider mid East conflict
blinkin met with Turkish president reip
T erdogan today emphasizing the need to
prevent the conflict from spreading
Anthony blinkin also spoke about
securing the release of hostages held in
Gaza expanding humanitarian assist
assistance and reducing civilian
casualties and according to the aid
group Doctors Without Borders the number
of children that are being killed every
day in Gaza since the outbreak of the
war is well over 100 and today after
days of artillery fighting in the
Palestinian territory and new evacuation
order leaflets being dropped this
morning in neighborhoods around the
aluxa hospital Doctors Without Borders
said it took the difficult decision to
evacuate its staff and their families
from the
area a powerful winter storm is plowing
through parts of the US and Canada this
weekend unleashing snow and freezing
rain along the east coast the system is
sweeping through much of the
Northeastern United States today and
it's making its way to Ontario where
several weather advisories are in effect
it's set to hit Atlantic Canada tomorrow
and that's where our Vanessa Wright has
more on how novas scotians are
preparing the first major snowstorm of
the season is marching East and packing
a punch several US cities are getting
hit with heavy snow the storm leaving
behind Chaos on its way to Atlantic
Canada in Nova Scotia there's this thing
with the weather it's
unpredictable Environment Canada issued
a special weather statement ahead of the
storm's arrival on Sunday Southern Nova
Scotia could see up to 25 cm of snow
with 15 cm possible in Western Halifax
we typically apply salt and bran ahead
of a weather event like this one and
then uh once the snow starts falling
crws will be out uh clearing snow as
quickly as possible the timeline of what
we're watching especially along the
Southshore of Nova Scotia it'll pick up
as early as the morning hours on Sunday
intensifying for the afternoon and
evening 15 and up to 25 cm is possible
and the winds the big weather story in
concern up to 70 kmet per hour we're
looking at blowing snow across the
region and while the snow is a welcome
sight for local businesses that thrive
on stormy weather the snow we get it'll
boost sales and we'll see people coming
in the door and going to the hills the
conditions are unwelcome for some living
rough this winter I wouldn't want my
roof to collapse on me again I didn't
like waking up that way it wasn't fun
Emergency Shelters are being set up in
Halifax Dartmouth and Lower Sackville
officials say Halifax ground search and
rescue will also be conducting Wellness
checks to several homeless
encampments Environment Canada says
these types of storms can cause
dangerous driving conditions school
closures and of course power outages as
such the city says residents play an
important role in keeping obstacles off
the sidewalks so operators can do their
jobs as quickly as possible Vanessa
Wright Global News
Halifax winter finally arrived in
Whistler BC as the skiers and
snowboarders couldn't wait to hit the
slopes but wait they did long lines
stretched around the ski resorts
Creekside Village Village and as you can
see could be seen from the highway an
abnormally warm winter has led to a lack
of snow on the Hills but more snow and
cooler temperatures are in the forecast
for this week and while we are seeing
snow in some areas of Canada it's the
lack off it and the drier than average
season we've just had that's causing
concern in other areas for the
agriculture sector as David Baxter
explains many farmers are worried even
though the growing season is still
months away up here at least up in East
Cola we usually have a B of snow up here
in the Orchards but Okanagan Valley
fruit farmer Manny Gill is left with
bare Brown fields and fruit trees that
won't Sprout until the spring grape
vines used to cover these fields but the
lack of snow put an end to that if it
does get really cold that BL that snow
creates a blanket it keeps the roots
warm and and then in the springtime when
it melts off it it moisturizes the soil
two Co snaps in a row have killed off
all the vine so I have to RI I ripped
out everything this year and I'm going
to replant it to an orchard next year
Gil is in the alone as of November 30th
the Canadian drought monitor says 72% of
the country is either abnormally dry or
in a drought that covers about 81% of
Canada's Farmland winter has been has
not happened yet and here we are I mean
the days are getting getting longer I
mean um we're clearly not to the the
dead of winter we still have a month to
go in the Prairies many fields depend on
snow melt to make moist spring soil for
sixth generation cash crop farmer Ian
box there's no need to worry quite yet
are we a little concerned about the lack
of snow sure but there's lots of time
for us in to scat to get snow we get
some heavy wet snow in March it'll make
up for the other months where we didn't
have any the east coast is one of the
few areas seeing more seasonal moisture
a welcome change after a spring drought
last year followed by heavy rainfall we
see a lot of variability coming with
with the the changing of the climates
and then big swings in terms of the
weather events and and uh
rainfalls uh temperatures those sorts of
things between droughts cold snaps and
storms this wild weather can be
devastating we're getting these major
weather events um that that can cause uh
crippling situations in in in various
Commodities back out west even though
Gil plans on replacing dead vines with
new fruit trees he says it will be at
least 5 years before they produce a crop
think of what you're going to plant and
you know in five years that might not be
the right decision David Baxter Global
News Ottawa
Global Affairs Canada confirms one
Canadian is dead and two others have
been injured after a bus heading from
Montreal to New York crashed on Friday
the deadly rollover happened about 260
kilometers south of Montreal in New York
state the cause of the incident is still
being investigated there were 23 people
on the bus at the time of the accident
most of them Canadian the gloves are off
on America's Insurrection anniversary
coming up how both leading candidates
for president are using the January 6th
Riot as a rallying cry and later why one
near endangered species is increasing in
[Music]
population the radical left Democrats
rigged the presidential election of 2020
and we're not going to let them rig at
the presidential election of 2024 we're
not going to let them do that's the
Republican front runner former US
president Donald Trump on the campaign
Trail in Iowa today pushing the big lie
on the anniversary of the January 6th
attack when Trump supporters stormed the
US capital three years on from that
attack new polling suggests Americans
are becoming more extreme and more
divided in their views of the
Insurrection it comes as Donald Trump's
attempts to overturn the 2020 election
becomes a key focus in the 2024 campaign
Jackson prco reports we will never give
up we will will never concede it doesn't
happen this is now effectively a
riot the echos of January 6th 2021 still
hang over the US
capital 3 years later what really
happened that day is increasingly
disputed by American voters it's more
than just people's memory fading there's
other things that are happening in terms
of the information environment over
1,200 riers were arrested former
president Donald Trump was impeached and
indicted you wouldn't know it from the
way many Republicans talk about January
6th today he didn't break into the
capital he gave an a fiery speech but
he's not the first guy to ever do that
for the past three years Trump and his
party have run a coordinated campaign to
rewrite history using baseless
conspiracy theories and outright lies
I'll pardon peaceful protesters from
January 6th that the evidence
increasingly suggested entrapment and
government involvement that message has
worked polls show that over the last 3
years Republican voters have become less
likely to believe that the attack was
violent and less likely to believe that
Donald Trump Bears any responsibility
for what happened less than a third of
Republican voters believe Joe Biden was
legitimately elected one in four now
believe January 6th was a setup by the
FBI 72% think it's time to move on
there's an extremist movement does not
share the basic beliefs in our democracy
USA in the 2024 presidential campaign
January 6th isn't being forgotten it's a
rallying cry especially for Democrats
I'm trying to rewrite the facts of
January 6th Trump is trying to steal
history the same way he tried to steal
the election the attack is also an
inescapable part of Donald Trump's
campaign he has been removed from
primary ballots in two states for
violating the so-called Insurrection
Clause of the US Constitution other
states could follow Joe Biden is a
threat to democracy he's a threat yet 3
years after he tried to overturn an
election Trump's support is as strong as
ever with so many Americans refusing to
agree on what happened experts warn it's
not hard to imagine it could all happen
again I think we have to take really
seriously the idea that this this might
not have been a one-time event Jackson
prco Global News
Washington on January 1st ahead why
Canada's most popular NDP Premier is
giving his Province a break from fuel
[Music]
taxes manitobans had more than one
reason to celebrate on New Year's Day
earlier this week as the provincial fuel
tax holiday came into effect from
January 1st until the end of June the
province's NDP government has
temporarily lifted a 14 c a liter
provincial tax on gasoline natural gas
and diesel fuel our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson spoke with Premier
wob Cano about the pause and what it
might mean for the federal carbon taxes
future in Manitoba
Mercedes far if the federal government's
New Year's wish was for a 2024 without
having to hear criticism about the
carbon tax well that's not going to
happen while most of the critiques have
been left by conservative Premier like
Alberta's Danielle Smith and
Saskatchewan's Scott mo Justin Trudeau
has also had to contend with a Critic
who it is much harder for him to dismiss
Manitoba Premier wab canu who is a new
democrat and one of the most if not the
most popular political leaders in Canada
right now according to the pools in an
interview with the West block Premier
Cano says the affordability crisis and
post holiday bills are mounting and that
means people need a break on carbon
price pricing he says he's doing his
part in giving manitobans a break on the
provincial fuel tax and now he wants the
feds to follow suit we know that people
are coming out of the holidays those
credit card statements are are starting
to arrive and so on January 1st we cut
the provincial fuel tax on gasoline and
Diesel just to give people uh a bit of a
break because we know that along with
healthc care affordability is another
major priority for manitobans I two
really interesting things there that you
just said I want to follow up on that
would you like to see the federal carbon
tax exemption extended to manitobans I
think that there's an argument uh that
Manitoba is maybe one of the strongest
cases you could make that uh the the
price on carbon should be Revisited in
our jurisdiction and so you know that's
something that I'd like to to to work on
and it's definitely something that I
know manitobans uh would like to see
some help with no sign of the federal
carbon tax Vanishing from the political
debate in Canada but a reminder to to
Canadians that the carbon tax is set to
rise again in April so expect to see
more political hay being made of this
issue in the new year we'll have more
with wob canoe on the west
block and as Mercedes mentioned you can
hear more for interview with Manitoba
Premier wab canoe Sunday on the west
block only here on
global next the African Mountain
gorilla's modest rebound how the species
bounced back from near
Extinction
[Music]
more than a quarter of monitored animal
species are being threatened with
Extinction that's about 44,000 types of
animals and among the most fascinating
of those creatures is the gorilla most
types of the animal are classified as
critically endangered however the
subspecies of mountain gorillas is
seeing its numbers slowly rebounding
Redmond Shannon
reports
on a mission through the clouds AK-47s
in hand these are not gorilla poachers
but gorilla
guides yes yes gorillas have moved are
looking for food they're following them
we're going to use another entrance on
the other side this tour guide is named
patience appropriate for such a delicate
job if you hear any any doing as I'm
going to do you have to pay attention if
it does like this like
cing uh either you are nearby him he
doesn't want you to keep approaching him
he wants you to move back all of a
sudden further up the side of a dormant
volcano there they
are a mountain gorilla
family the silver back his six females
and their infants the mountain gorilla
is classified as endangered but is the
only type of gorilla not critically
endangered its numbers across this small
part of East Africa now around
1,000 up from 680 in 2008 thanks to
anti- poaching patrols and the removal
of snares when you you meet them uh they
are right they close to humans there's
something that I don't understand I
don't understand how people can come to
kill this beautiful animals relate to
humans genetically we the same so
they can catch a cold from us which can
even be fatal our understanding of them
is thanks to people like patients and
conservationist Diane FY her 1985 murder
thought to be linked to her work against
poachers yeah it's time for for having
break for socializing they have like a
like a biological clock by this time all
goras they break for digesting what they
ate in the morning and socializing the
relative peace and stability in Rwanda
is an important factor in helping them
thrive in the neighboring Democratic
Republic of the Congo plagued by
conflict their safety and future is less
assured Redmond Channon Global News
London and that's global national for
this Saturday night I'm faren Asser on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
the ring in Montreal Quebec we love
seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing us your photos to viewers at
global.com until we're together again
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good
[Music]
night